issue that concerns many american
families one missouri man says he got an
emergency room bill for more than a
thousand dollars even though a doctor
never saw his son we are looking at that
surprising bill as part of our bill of
the month series with kaiser health news
and npr duvall bot says his wife and
toddler waited to see a doctor at the
hospital for more than an hour then they
eventually left without being seen by
any md
and they were shocked when they still
got a more than thousand dollar bill
the hospitals can
charge you
crazy amounts and
this is what i had heard from my friends
deval bod an immigrant from india always
avoided hospitals in america because he
feared large medical bills but when his
two-year-old son burned his hand on the
stove in april bot's wife mancy called
their pediatrician who told them go to
the hospital i was very much worried the
blisters came on his hand so at that
time i was really panicked the hospital
coded it as a level three a moderately
severe problem
nancy says a nurse looked at her son's
vitals looked at his wound and said a
surgeon would look at it more closely
but after waiting more than an hour they
decided to leave without seeing a doctor
it was so annoying and frustrating i was
just thinking that why isn't someone
coming to to take a look at my son if
this
his wound was so severe
their son's hand healed on its own after
a few days and then the hospital bill
arrived one thousand twelve dollars and
bot owed more than 850 after the
insurance adjustments almost all of the
bill was the facility fee something
hospitals can charge for anyone who
walks in and registers even if they
don't get treated i was really
astonished to see like such a crazy bill
when nothing was done
to my son after contacting the hospital
several times to fix the issue his bill
was sent to collections
bot says facility fees don't exist in
india and the concept of them still does
not make sense to him if you compare it
to like just walking to the grocery
store you don't get charged for just
entering the room or the place where you
have been to like if you don't get any
services you don't pay
make sense to me bot also filed a
complaint with his insurance company and
his state's department of health no luck
on either front the hospital did
eventually waive the facility fee that
was back in november after a kaiser
health news reporter got involved and
bot's bill was lowered to just
38
how they came up with 38 is a mystery uh
that's the cost for seeing the nurse
actually
uh in a statement the hospital said the
patient was treated by a nurse nurse
practitioner
supervisor for a burn and referred for
follow-up care and they also said that
the charge was appropriate
based on factors including a traumatic
wound assessment
adding that they post information about
pricing online and at their care sites
the editor-in-chief of kaiser health
news dr elizabeth rosenthal joins us now
um
elizabeth it makes sense to me to be
shocked at a facility fee you think if
you walk in if you're not seen and
getting detailed care you're not going
to get
a bill just for you know having the
doors open uh but apparently it's common
practice so what are facility fees and
how regular are they
yeah right um facilities fees are a
construct of american medicine well
actually american medical billing
they're basically a room usage fee and
they started when emergency rooms said
look we need facility fees to cover the
cost of overhead 24 7. but they've
trickled down now so we even get
facility fees for people who are doing
telemedicine visits when they're sitting
in their own bedroom like
i'm already paying rent for that and you
know in emergency rooms they can be a
lot they're often the biggest part of
the bill
so as a parent there there are often
issues that are kind of on the line
where something is urgent but you're not
sure if you should wait a day and go to
the pediatrician or go to the er as this
family did so when people consider an
emergency room visit what factors should
they evaluate
well you know i can't give medical
advice but often there is that moment of
panic and you should know that if you go
to an emergency room a the charges are
going to be very very high and b
especially during the pandemic weights
are likely to be long and you'll get
exposure there
and and you know emergency rooms they
treat people
based on how sick they are not based on
how long you wait so it's worth thinking
twice calling a doctor visiting urgent
care something like that
so when it comes to ers i mean most most
things in your life you can call around
to a couple retailers ask the price of
something if you want to order a pizza
you can check a few menus can you do
that for emergency rooms is a way of
knowing the price ahead of time and
price comparing
well i mean if you have a degree in
coding and medical billing probably all
hospitals since 2019 have to post their
charge masters their master price list
online but they're often in code and
they're hundreds of pages long and er
facility fees come in levels one to five
which each level up being charged more
so in theory you could know but um you
know you in practice it's impossible
dr elizabeth rosenthal thank you very
much for laying it out so clearly much
appreciated we'll see you again soon